this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
dolone ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money if you've not
talked to checked out the dr john delony
show and um been on it it's on monday
wednesday and friday on youtube anywhere
you listen to podcasts as well uh his
book best-selling book is called
redefining
anxiety
and i'm working on a new book now
that'll come out next year we'll tell
you more about all of that so be sure
you check it out if you want to
participate in his show it's all about
relationships and mental health and
anxiety and boundaries and crazy people
in your family and all that kind of
stuff or maybe you're the crazy person
in your family i don't know all that
kind of crazy bosses whoa oh careful
careful so it's about boundaries too
boundaries
it's about decorum what to do when
you're unemployed right
how do i spend your unemployment money
[Laughter]
oh it's a hostile working environment
pack your office john it's a hostile
work environment that's warning you
okay so just ahead of time you need to
know these things
uh you can email john at askjohn
ramseysolutions.com for god's sakes get
on the show because uh he needs some
callers no he has a ton
poor kelly
leave a voicemail at
844-693-3291 if you want to talk to john
but by the way you could talk to him
here today
and uh if you get through the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five hope is with us in
midland texas hi hope how are you
hi how are you guys doing today better
than we deserve what's up
well first off i just want to say what a
pleasure it was to see both of you at
summit this year in dallas that was very
enjoyable thank you thank you for coming
it was a great event we had a lot of fun
it was great
um
my question today actually uh just a
background my husband and i together
started our own business 13 years ago
and
[Music]
it's just
over the last four or five years it's
gone downhill he and i have a lot of
issues with communicating
almost to the extent of not
communicating at all but
it is affecting our business
a great deal because he and i are not on
the same page as far as
strategy how to how to go about the
operation of the business and get it
going
so i guess my question is what kind of
advice you might would have a
relationship as well as just keeping our
business afloat and moving it forward
when we're not on the same page at all
how's your marriage
uh suffering yeah because of it
is it the chicken or the egg is
are they self-reinforcing one another
my guess is things were tough at home
and they become tough in the office and
they become tougher at home and the
thing just spins faster and faster
have you guys
stepped away from everything and
gone over to dallas for a weekend just
to say hey what in the world's going on
or is this thing just started spinning
so fast and all of a sudden you look up
and it's a year or two later and you're
not talking anymore
um it just kind of spun and then and
yeah like you said two or three years
later now
things are just so totally out of
control and we were talking to him when
he said there's a problem too
oh yes okay yeah yeah this is one of
those moments that
can it can be a
really important it's going to be an
important moment either way but it can
be um something not to be feared it can
be a beautiful moment when there's
redefining rebuilding excavation start
over rebuilding moments but it's got to
have to happen somebody's got to turn
the lights off i mean turn the lights on
turn the music off
take an inventory of the party you've
been having and saying hey where are we
what's going on
and um
i love it when couples can look each
other in the eye and say hey we need to
do this and have this moment this we
need to take a post-mortem on what's
happened and decide where we're going to
go but somebody's got to just say stop
for a second
yeah you guys need you guys need a good
marriage counselor in your corner asap
to start with and just
the business will not heal until your
marriage does
right we we have done marriage
counseling literally a little about a
year and a half ago um
and apparently you didn't do it well
right
apparently not
why didn't it go well why didn't it go
well
um
he kind of just checks out um we've even
done business coaching and
uh
you know i think two different
counselors a business coach literally
fired us a year and a half ago or two
years ago because he wouldn't
participate
we were in coaching for 15 months and he
just
wouldn't do his part of it he would
wouldn't schedule for our weekly
sessions things like that he just
wouldn't he just checks out and it's not
doesn't even give any reason just checks
out and doesn't do it
and it was kind of the same way in our
marriage counseling i mean he attended
because we went together but
he would just kind of clam up and and
nothing really was being said from his
his point and he did tell me he didn't
like the the counselor
uh the marriage counselor that he didn't
like him he didn't trust him or
something and um it just didn't go
anywhere and
literally since that time we've just
kind of quit talking
literally
so your your your relationship
if you stop and step out of it for a
minute it's on life support
yes
um
and i would say you're you're in an
emergency status and it sounds like
you've got a guy that's that is
unable to say hey i'm done with this
thing is unable doesn't it i don't want
to blame doesn't have the tools or it's
a coward or whatever you want to say but
he's unable to say i'm through with this
thing and he's going to slowly suffocate
it
and somebody's got to turn all the
lights on in that house and send the
kids away for a weekend and say we've
gotta we gotta take an inventory because
what he's communicating to you is he is
finished and he doesn't have the courage
to say he's done or he's scared of you
or he doesn't want to be in this
business anymore he doesn't know how to
say it out loud somehow he is um
slowly pulling this thing under water
counseling we call it the one down
position but he's drowning the house
slowly but surely
and um usually the your your role in
this is to try to keep yanking as hard
as you can the other direction and it
just creates this tension that ends up
sinking the boat anyway
so you've got to just stop stop the
music and say
are you done with this marriage i'm not
going to continue to participate in
crazy the way it exists no
i'm going to say
we're going to do something different
now do you want to work on this and heal
it
if you do that involves you finding a
counselor that you trust that we can sit
down with and that you're willing to
open up in front of and thus to get this
stuff fixed otherwise it's just going to
continue to deteriorate this is not
working you know continuing to do the
same thing over and over again expecting
a different result
insanity and you know and if you're
seeking outside direction and you're not
taking the direction from outside that's
him
there has to be a reason yeah
and um
you know i can buy i i've sat down with
people that i didn't trust and i'm not
gonna open up in front of them
absolutely i'm not doing that i can buy
that as a reason but the the answer is
not nothing then
the answer is go find a different
counselor right go find one you can he's
communicating to you
if he won't find another counselor that
is a that's a communication to you that
i'm done
with this or he just doesn't have the
tools to to work this through whatever
it is but yeah you got to have somebody
in your corner at least guiding you
through these tough uh
discussions that you have got to have
immediately the business has not got a
chance until the marriage does
[Music]
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health sharing ministry chm
has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five
all right john you are a phd in
counseling and you've done a lot of
trauma work
and you've done a lot of work with
couples over the years as well
um
if you were just gonna you may know some
research off the top of your head to
answer this but you may also have just
an anecdotal feel for it
um
when a spouse
for
uh virtually for for no
obvious reason that's on the surface
that's in front of us
turns away repeated counseling
and stonewalls in counseling
what percentage of the time
is there a third party involved in a
fair
i don't have any data but that's my
first
that's that's my cool that's my number
one question i always ask somebody are
you seeing somebody else
are you done right have you if they're
saying i don't want to work on this or
the are they or they sabotage
all the counseling
by not showing up or by showing up
physically but not emotionally
um
not relationally and so on they're not
engaged in the repair right
that that will be one of the first
questions i asked if not the first is
are you seeing somebody else are you
through with this this interaction here
are you done with this person it's like
going to the doctor
and the doctor says
let me do a checkup on you and you just
say no i'm good
and they say well here's some medicine
i'm good
like at some point you are deciding to
not be a part of the solution here and i
want to know why but yeah but
i'm trying to think of otherwise
the only other only other why that comes
to mind is somebody has such they grew
up in a family that's so maligned
counseling
that's for losers or idiots or
psychopaths or crazies and you don't
need to go to counseling that's a shrink
that's for yeah head shrinkers yeah it's
for losers maybe
the sense of failure is so great
or man if i can't say the right thing to
make my wife okay i feel like i mean
that that makes me feel like a loser
right i get that and so it could be
something that shame is so heavy but i
want to rattle that cage and i'm gonna
ask are you cheating on me are you
seeing somebody else right
um i just can't think of a reason other
than those two reasons why somebody
would it comes up i mean
again i'm not in that world but i end up
in that world too often because the
money you are in that world the money
piece ends up on the marriage plate the
marriage piece ends up on the money
plate and so i end up and i'm you know
this guy is completely disconnected this
guy's completely disconnected i can't
get him to engage in anything on the
money stuff and i'm like
they're not staying right for some
reason or another they're not staying
and sometimes when the person calls and
asks that question dave we all have
friends like this
my wife's crazy my wife's crazy my
wife's crazy you talk to your wife and
you go no brother you are right and so
it could be that this is round 10 of
some
thing that she wants to fix and he's
like i'm not doing another one of your
schemes because you won't participate so
you always get we always get one side on
the show that's true but so i'm not
saying that happened with her or him
necessarily
yeah yeah but but i but it just made me
wonder during the commercial break
from your perspective because you've got
a lot more professional insight than i
do on it mine's just an old guy hanging
around with a whole bunch of hurting
people for a lot of years and it just
gives me a sense of these things but
what do you think uh i would say north
of 50 yeah
that's my i just a wet finger in there
though i have nothing to base it on i'm
just i just because i can't there
and it might be that they gave up on the
situation and then went and got the
affair rather than the affair causing
them to give up on the situation i don't
i don't know which one
that is but they're gone right they just
hadn't left yet that's right
and some people don't have the tools i
don't know how to end the marriage i
don't know how to break up i don't want
to be the one that's the bad guy so i'm
just going to say up is hard to do i'm
going to yeah there you go i'm just
going to drown this thing right slowly
but surely suffocated
and then by the way on the way down i'm
going to make you feel crazy okay
yeah yeah so who knows but i i just
don't again we're not saying that's the
last caller no
i just it just made me question and made
me wonder
i wanted and i wanted to ask you in
front of everybody else kenzie is in des
moines iowa hi kenzie welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave hey what's up
well my question today i'm going to try
to explain this as fast as i can um is i
recently got engaged in april
um
we before i met my fiance he had
purchased land he has 40 acres
and i was renting
so i have a rental
our question or my question is we're
trying to figure out we're getting
married next year in july
what
we are trying to figure out do we build
a house on a 40 acre
together do we find a trailer house to
throw out there or do we rent the house
together and so
um either the land is paid off or i am
out of debt
either the land
i'm sorry the land is paid off and
you're out of debt what'd you say
yeah so the
he still owes money on the land
um i am not i'm on baby step two
um and so
when we get married
you should you should you should rent
until you get out of debt
okay and you should not buy a trailer
because trailers go down in value those
two things are easy then the only
question is are we going to build on
this 40 acres after you're out of debt
right that's the only question remaining
do you want to live on the 40 acres i
kind of hear in your voice you don't
yeah
no actually i really do like where it
lives we're just trying to figure out do
we find somewhere else to live and buy a
house or do we build why would you build
somewhere else if you want to live on
the 40 acres
i don't i don't know i don't know
we would just probably little 40 acres
yeah you need to be debt you need to be
debt free other than the acreage you
guys need to be clear of that and you
need to be married now i also would tell
you that building a house is a large and
complicated project for a brand new
marriage to undertake
it makes it makes a 25-year marriage
have some world-class fights
a 25-day marriage woo you are putting it
at risk
because i mean you can you can kill each
other over freaking curtains
okay thank you dave so you need to be
real careful
i i'm not sure i would say hey the
smartest thing you can do right after
you get married to build a house
together as a matter of fact i can say
that's going to put an extra strain on a
very young and tender marriage and i
probably wouldn't recommend it but not
to the point i tell you not to do it but
it's just it's just you're asking for
trouble and you better be watching for
trouble because he's gonna knock on your
door while you're doing this john yeah
and by the way in a year when you're
married your debt is y'all's debt and
that acreage debt is y'alls that right
yes this is something y'all gonna put in
in this order in the snowball order and
you're gonna pay it off together there
yeah work your way right through the
whole thing very good
jeremy's in detroit hey jeremy welcome
to the ramsay show well thanks a lot for
taking my call sure um so my what my
wife and i have been angsting over a car
purchase for a little bit and kind of
want to see what you think but maybe how
much money do you enter
um right now we've got 25k emergency
fund 80k liquid investments 60k in our
kids college fund great what are you
talking about spending on your car
um i would like a tesla model 3
performance it's a 65 000 car is that a
used car
now this this would be new are you are
you have a million dollar net worth
1.8 yep okay
um
and what's your household income
so i make a 196k a year wow like six
buy the car pretty easy huh well you
have the money you have the money it's a
small percentage of your income you have
a net worth of two million dollars this
is a 65 000 car
okay you're not buying you're not asking
you're not buying a 250 000 lamborghini
no no maybe in another decade or two but
well not maybe another couple of million
in net worth and you know but
but uh because you want your you want
your rolling stock anything with wheels
and motors totaled up to be less than
half your annual income and it is
yeah even with that i've got bonuses and
other stuff and you obviously need to
pay cash for it because you called dave
freaking ramsey right
yes yep yeah it would come out of the
liquid and you don't buy a new car
unless you have over a million dollar
net worth and you do
ta-da you got a tesla congratulations
you don't get a lot of people calling
dave for permission to buy a tesla and
him saying go buy the car so don't push
your luck brother go buy the tesla
quit asking questions to go buy the
tesla you know
it's the guidelines that's right i don't
tell people to not have a good life i
tell them to get yourself in a position
that they do have a good life get the
tesla
get the tesla i guess
james cut that keep it it is a tesla but
there's that but
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage scott and diane are with
us hey guys how are you wonderful
welcome where do you guys live in the st
louis area uh just across the river
whatever illinois yeah about 30 minutes
north good to have you guys so welcome
welcome welcome how much debt have you
paid off a hundred and fifty five
thousand dollars yay and how long did
this take seven years eight months okay
excellent and your range of income
during that time seventy five thousand
to ninety with a coveted backslide last
year about thirty percent cut last year
that's a bite yeah ouch yes and yet we
still paid off the house
wow
house and everything yeah completely
free complete yes how old are you guys
i'm 49 she's i'm 52. all right
your condition i will not say that
number exactly i will see yes
and let her face
when we started dating i was 18 he was
15. that works excellent you guys what's
this house worth about 225 000.
excellent
wow you've been doing this stuff for
eight years well longer than that we
actually started in 2010 and we were
here in 2012 and signed the wall that's
around the corner yeah um and paid off
36 172 then yeah and then started baby
step 3b so you were on the original debt
free wall that was beside the old studio
yes right in the middle right on the m
we cut the drywall out and moved it
around made it a display around the
corner from the hallway have you found
your old signature yeah yeah yeah that's
cool
and that was 2012 2012 yeah so uh gosh
almost 10 years ago yeah yeah wow you
guys this is amazing
how's it feel uh
it's still days is not real you know and
uh but it is so much more freedom
and you didn't realize how heavy that
burden was
you know until you started making a plan
to get rid of it yeah and and now it's
gone have you had the first month
where there's no mortgage payment yeah
we paid it off at the end of march so
we've had a couple months of no payments
and i'm the one that usually balances
checkbook and pays the bills and it
still doesn't just feels weird
it doesn't feel right like you missed
something exactly
that's a lot of money on that side of
the ledger right yeah exactly it's funny
when you've been carrying a bunch of
weight for a long time you put it down
your arm feels weird it feels like
you're still
you guys very well done what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
the key is is the budget that's
absolutely we have not missed a budget
since march 2010 yes and doing the
budget together and
coming up with the the same goals and
dreams and outlook and so
those two things working together
because we were both sort of on the same
page but not totally and so you know
even if we're both going
sorry this direction you know even if we
were like this then it recorrected us
and and got us going both the same
direction with the same goals and
and dreams so you've been working the
baby steps all the time putting the 15
away oh yeah oh yeah so what are your
investments looking like uh real well uh
when we started this you know back in
2010 our net worth was negative
uh we are healthy six figures probably
hopefully millionaire status the next
three to four years yeah you should be
there yeah should be there shortly yeah
that's what i was thinking with that
house paid off and everything yeah way
to go guys baby steps millionaires look
at you yeah how do you keep doing this
for seven years
well that's a long time a couple things
as diane said we were focused together
and also we have coordinated fpu 18
times whoa so we have lots of
accountability partners throughout our
community you can't let all those people
down no no no no so we probably have
600 to 700 people have gone through it
that we've got as accountability
partners yeah that'll do it yeah yeah
that'll do it yeah and then also i mean
just watching and re-watching fpu and
each time
you know there would be new things that
i'm like i don't remember him saying
that before and so i mean we still took
notes the 18th time time
time i don't know if i've watched it
[Laughter]
wow so all the jokes are still funny to
me
you're so precious thank you
thank you i love you you're amazing
you're my kind of people yes and it's
still funny to me but i laugh at
everything yes it's so great that's so
great that's fun way to go you guys yeah
we're so proud of you thank you
congratulations we couldn't have done it
without the the pathway that you made
for us thank you and and you walked it
and ran it and ran it and walked it and
stumbled and did it yeah well done
very very well put two kids through
college during that too yes oh really
yes wow yeah no student loans oh no no
guys you got to lead with that and
that's great too
that's bigger than paying off a couple
of other houses you paid off right yeah
wow yeah that's a big deal so now you've
launched two kids out in the world with
no student loan debt
and their parents have a fully paid for
house they're not gonna have to put you
guys in a retirement home and you've
completely changed the legacy absolutely
incredible are they behaving oh yes both
of them are doing very well yes our
son's still at home he has high
functioning autism so he'll probably
stay with us for a little while but he
has had a job since he was 16 and um is
saving for his retirement saving for his
first house and our daughter's out on
her own and working for the same company
that i worked for when she was a baby
wow
absolutely loves it and she's been able
to get an apartment with no credit no
credit score it can't be done it can't
be done is there anything we tell people
to do that they have not done
this is amazing she's brought her car
she bought two cars with cash
how do you do that the next generation
she's a financial piece we're screwing
up a lot of people's
all the excuses are gone now that you're
here yeah no excuses that's so fun well
done
well we've got a copy of the legacy
journey you probably have one but i'm
gonna give you another one i'll give you
a copy of the total money makeover i
know you had one of those but i'm gonna
give you another one and you can give
both of them away to somebody and pay it
forward that'll be awesome we're so
proud of y'all thank you congratulations
thanks for sharing a great story of just
being heroes just taking control of your
life very very well done thank you for
the opportunity scott and diane say
louis every 155 000 paid off seven and
eight seven years eight months making 75
to 90. house and everything we're
looking at weird people
count it down let's hear a debt free
[Music]
[Applause]
that is how it's
done that's so cool man doesn't get any
better than that
you know that this is uh
financial peace university uh 18 times
wow we're running a free trial on that
right now with ramsey plus 18 times you
you i guess during the free trial if you
just binge watch it over and over you
could probably do it 18 times during the
free trial but you probably wouldn't get
much else done during that time but uh
yeah yeah and it includes the every
dollar budgeting app which wasn't there
when they started nope um the lessons
are certainly updated and polished and
everything else since they started uh
but if you want to jump onto ramsey plus
and get the free trial you can go
through financial peace university uh
you can be budgeting with every dollar
during the free trial there's other
classes there's community there's
coaches there uh because uh you could be
scott and diane someday
no house payments just think about it
for a second no payments on their kids
nothing everybody went to school
debt-free nothing they did like every
baby step man paid kids college
did retirement they're almost
millionaires
baby step millionaires on the way
they're still holding hands they still
like each other i don't even know what
to do that's incredible she did have to
shake his hand loose to make sure he did
points
yeah
yeah that's great all right text trial
and you can get a free trial ramsey plus
and go through financial peace
university right now
text trial to three three
seven eight nine
text trial to thirty three
seven
eighty nine
you know it's uh
we we lay these baby steps and all the
nuances around them out and we talk
about them because it's the framework by
which we teach you to make decisions
because that's how we're going to answer
questions here as well as far as the
financial part of the question goes
anyway
relational question there's a whole
different set of
of rules that you'll get into
but the uh are guidelines or principles
that you'll get into but the uh
that's what we envision when we talk
this through is that somebody that
actually does it yeah
and if you actually do it it works
like what years ago we used to have a
money-back guarantee everybody said
y'all have a money-back guarantee so i
had a money-back guarantee if you go to
the class and do the stuff in the class
it works
if you don't it won't
did you ever give anybody's money back i
would have but nobody asked because they
they're too ashamed they didn't go to
class or they did it and it works every
time
every time now you don't want your money
back if you do today and work hello
that's the thing that's incredible this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today lane is women with us in
wilmington delaware hi lane how are you
i'm good how are you guys doing great
what's up
um so in march i passed my occupational
therapy board so i have my master's in
occupational therapy however last year i
started a landscaping business it's been
full time so rather than getting a
therapy job
i went ahead and
did the landscaping full-time it's been
a great source of income
i have twelve thousand dollars left in
debt and i'm honestly just kind of burnt
out so i was trying to transition into
my therapy job now so i have less
landscaping jobs and i'm kind of in a
weird limbo
where i have accepted an outpatient
pediatric job which i'm very passionate
about but it's only one day a week and
so that's not enough and i'm having a
hard time finding places that i'll take
me for the other four days
why did you leave the job you had before
you had another job
so i didn't i am a small business owner
so i
i couldn't grow any more without hiring
someone and i didn't want to have to do
that because then you make less i don't
have a problem i don't have a problem
with that i'm just saying why'd you shut
it down before you had the new job lined
up
oh so i i did not shut it down okay um
i'm still doing it but i have less jobs
now than i did
so did you intentionally take fewer jobs
um yes i did because i honestly was
burnt out and my attention to detail was
going down and i didn't want to provide
people services to that mindset
um and i was ready to get started with
my professional career for what i went
to school with
um that part i'm in complete alignment
on it's just the timing thing yeah
right
um
what did you say it was the timing thing
you dropped you stepped off of one
income
to no income
i just would i would have loved for you
to have had your i mean i'd love for you
have just gotten uh you know your your
occupational therapy job and just quit
landscaping
right it's so getting credentialed
through insurance takes like a month so
actually a month ago i sent in some
applications and then i found out now
after i already dwindled down the job
that getting credentialed through
insurance takes some time
and i do have twelve thousand dollars
left of debt which i feel like is eating
me alive um and i kind of feel like a
bum having eaten like two days off a
week
um
so this is kind of just like a
i don't know i can't go anywhere i could
go to a really great restaurant and
apply and work there and make money but
you know who knows in a month i might
have to say i have to leave you know i
don't think you're morally right to do
so listen listen listen
you're cooked yeah
okay
and i've sat with i can't even tell you
how many students who have finished
their boards or finish the bar exam or
finish whatever
and they're just cooked
and so where you find yourself is you
are fried but you did jump off
you you chose to stop paying attention
to detail because you got tired
right it's not something that happened
to you it's something that you chose to
do
you are just zonked okay and what
happens when you get zonked sometimes
you start catastrophizing and start
creating situations that then you try to
solve that haven't even happened yet
so what i'd love to see you do
is go find somebody in your community
you can talk to just go talk to a
counselor once or twice just go find
something or go out with your friends
have people over to your house i want
you to be
human again
okay you've been a robot attacking tasks
for a long time yeah
you've been in fight or flight for years
okay you're gonna have to take some more
lawn jobs
and do some more landscaping jobs until
you land a full-time job and then here's
what you do you call your landscape
clients and say i'm getting out of this
and so here's your two-week notice and
then you move on
right and they will find somebody else
but you have over thought this and
overspun this because your body's cooked
and you just need to start laughing
again and invite some friends over to
your house again you gotta make some
money so you're gonna have to pick up
some more jobs again if you just can't
start that lawnmower one more time then
go get a job at a restaurant i just
don't know why you wouldn't just do it
for another five or six months
getting your boards it's fr you thought
you were gonna ride into a new job as
soon as you pass that test we're gonna
start on monday and then you realize are
you freaking kidding me there's more
hurdles yes there's more hurdles
and so now you're right back in it take
some more jobs
make some more money but start being a
person make the transition by christmas
yeah
but don't make it by tuesday don't make
it by tuesday you're so close honey
you're so close and you're so strong and
you've made it you're going to be good
but you're not quite there yet
okay so maybe make like christmas my
headline you're saying i don't care i
just made it i'm trying i just made that
up tired of the landscaping yeah you're
hey you're tired but you're so close
this is a terrible example and i wish i
had another one off top of my head but
this is live radio you know when you're
in a long car ride and you got to pull
over because you got to go
and then it feels right when you get to
the gas station all of a sudden it
becomes a super emergency right that's
where you're at that's where you feel
you just gotta hang in there okay don't
go in the car wait till you get inside
okay
maybe the the worst live radio analogy i
think it probably qualifies as one of
the worst ever
hey i know you're fried i want you to
have some people over this week you'll
watch a movie you get some pizza it's a
glass of wine y'all laugh
but start re-engaging humanity again
you're strong enough to hang on
to do the transition wisely
instead of this gap that you left
between the incomes which is now scaring
you more than the burnout scared you
does that make sense i have no reason to
stress financially i just got married in
june and
you know i'm we're everything's great so
yeah
your stress is not about math it's not
about math your stress is that your body
has been in fight or flight it's been on
cortisol and adrenaline for years
and it finally just said enough you've
been cranking through these tasks
and it's just you you've you've been
in a a machine in a good way but very
robotic but but uh it got you through
there and you can go you can go from
here
so you got the stuff it takes you're
just gonna have to make this transition
a little more gentle
uh because it's driving you nuts yeah
genie is are more gradual i don't know
incremental jeannie's in tampa florida
hi genie how are you
hello dave john i'm will thank you very
much thank you so much for all you do
thank you how can we help
um i am 59 years old getting ready to
reinvent my life
after 30 some odd years out of the
traditional job market and i'm trying to
decide if it makes more sense to sell my
home
and relocate to a less expensive area
for a fresh start
why are you reinventing your life at 59
i love your spirit in that language what
what what's going on
sadly i'm facing a divorce after 33
years of marriage
that's hardly a reinvention
when was it final
um it isn't yet um i feel i'm kind of in
the process of that um right now turned
out after coming the financial piece in
2009 i didn't have a financial problem
we had unfortunately a relationship
problem
so
i had my eot over last night and i got a
price for the house what i could sell my
home for my home is paid for
however after it was all paid for it
ended up getting an equity line on it so
i do actually have two debts that would
need to come out of the home if i chose
to sell it what are you using for income
after the divorce
uh that's a bit of an issue um i
actually i belong to business boutique
and
by trade i'm a writer and so as you well
know with the publishing market the way
that it is it's been kind of um changing
so um i've been self-employed for 30
years now and so i'm going to have to
kind of
figure
sort of figure that out
trying to get a job hasn't been working
but you know i do have attendant money
so
um how much money do you have
will you have what will you have when
the smoke clears
the house i'm sitting in it that's it
what's the house worth that's it
225 according to the erp lady who was
very nice
if we could get your income going so i
knew you had something to live on i
would tell you to slow down and not sell
it fast
okay unless the house holds memories and
emotions that you'd rather get away from
that's part of the problem they have
quite frankly it's it's kind of my my
support system is here but that said it
is like all i want to do is full run
this has been going on for quite a while
now unfortunately and you want to clean
you want the white board wiped off
i don't mind you selling that i don't
you know what i do is just sell a house
and rent for six months but what i would
also do is not touch the money don't
touch it go get your money go get a job
and make make enough money to survive
without touching the money don't use
this money to
be your fresh start go get a job
anywhere go get you a nice apartment
somewhere get you a fresh emotional
well-being around you but don't spend
the money
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
talk about your life and your money it's
a free call at triple eight eight two
five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five
two two five kisha is in wichita kansas
hi keisha how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can john and i help
well um
i don't
honestly i'm not sure that i'm asking
the right question but
i
i'm struggling with feeling like
if i approach my mother-in-law i
disrespect my husband
because my mother-in-law
talks negatively about me to family and
friends when she is upset
and
honestly i'm not sure why it started
shortly after we
became married we've been married almost
six years have two great children
and it's just kind of getting worse so i
don't
i know i can't control other people but
i want to support and respect my husband
in every which way because
he leads a wonderful family
and so give me an example
when she gets upset give me an example
of that
so the most recent was she was in a
disagreement with
her other son
and um
she then called him disrespectful
and isn't sure where he learned that and
said that i must be rubbing off on him
as well
so did um immediately tell his mom do
not disrespect my wife no that was her
son her brother that was that that was
my brother-in-law um but he shared he
shared that with my husband and yes my
my husband immediately
talked to her and said
don't ever do this again okay um you
know but but this is
it's not the first time and i know it's
not going to be the last time so how is
her what's her reaction when herself
what
when her son calls her on the carpet
your husband
and says hey mom you can't talk about my
wife like that come on what's your
problem uh stop it what did she say
right
there's no apologies there's blaming of
either him or i
um
she's never wrong
with it
okay so there's really there's really
two choices you got
right choice number one is
let your husband know hey i i'm feeling
this
burning in my soul i want to sit down
with her and just ask
i'd love to make peace with the
grandparents of my kid the grandmother
of my kids
right you'd have to understand and you
make peace with the fact that peace may
never come
and
at the end of the day
you've got to
unhit yourself
from this woman who's just choosing to
bring poison into your life
and i know that sounds trite and silly
and how am i supposed to do that
at the end of the day you're gonna have
to make a decision that old lady can
just say whatever she's gonna say
but i'm gonna love my kids i'm a good
wife i'm a good friend i'm a good
neighbor
i got a great husband and i'm going to
go about my life i'm not going to let
her dictate my world
right i i am a i'm personally a fan of
face-to-face conversations but i've had
to make peace over the years with the
fact that some people a don't want to
have them with me or b
they have no interest in any sort of
reconciliation because like you said
they're narcissistic
yeah they're never wrong
but i always want to know i went down
swinging on that one
yeah you gave it every shot so
it might be that that you you and your
husband and uh your father-in-law and
mother-in-law go to dinner one night you
all buy
and just say um
you know
i'm not trying to correct you at all i
just want to tell you that we love you
we respect you
and i don't want anything but good
things between us
and i and i won't be ever saying
anything bad about you behind your back
ever
right you can count on me
to cut to take your back i'll always
take your side behind your back
and if if i ever have any issue with you
um
either your son or i will discuss it
with you we will not discuss it with
other people
and we just want you to know that we
love you and respect you and and gosh if
you could do that for us that would be
the greatest gift in the world but even
if you don't we love you we respect you
and you're the grandparents of our kids
and it just seems like it just shames
the crud out of it it's the old bible
verse about heaping coles right yeah
if you can't have a in person you can
write a letter just tell her i'm glad
you're the grandmother of my kids i love
you and i want you to respect you and um
like i love that
i hope that you'll do the same for me if
you ever have any challenge with me
please give me a shout but here's the
thing
some people make a decision to be test
pilot for a broom factory
and and this woman is she she's like a
second degree lieutenant test pilot for
the broom factory
that's what she is and so if she just
decides i'm gonna be a the rest
of my life and you're attached to her
through her son you just have that
attachment and you just go that's the
crazy one over there in the corner look
at her check out the pointed hat you
know i mean so that's just you know you
just have to kind of put that in your
head and kind of grin and go on because
every family's got something right
right
that is that is very true
it's hard but
that's where you said it you said it
early in the conversation you said it
you said
i can't control her
so i mean you've intellectually got that
part but the problem put it down the
next trip is to emotionally get that
part there you go i can't control her
because here's what you're trying to do
you're trying to figure out what it is
you're doing and you're not doing
anything you're not doing anything
there's something way back in her
childhood that just is in in her
interaction with her husband or
something who knows i don't know
somewhere along the line hurting people
hurt people and usually these situations
are real frustrating for me because we
got a husband who won't step up to his
mom and that's not the case here you got
a man i love your husband i love your
husband it's awesome
and he's going to i do too
yeah
he's good he's a he's you know because
usually i i get this wife i get this
call and i'm dealing with a wuss and a
husband he will stand up to his little
mommy right you know and this guy's a
stud
and he wasn't mean to her he just called
her out
yeah but in her world anybody in in her
little narcissistic world anybody who
calls her out is called mean yeah you're
just so mean so here's here's the messy
part of this
you have a fantasy in your head
about christmas and thanksgiving
that has these perfect grandparents that
welcome your kids and they run out of
the car and they hug you
and you can call her about challenges
with your
kid this doesn't exist you're just gonna
have the halloween character show up
after thanksgiving you gotta let the
fantasy go and i hate that for you
but it's most families it's most famous
it is it is but i we all have the
fantasy and it's in awe
it's like freaking leave it to beaver
did this to this culture we all think
june cleaver's out there somewhere
and she's
i don't know where she went i think she
died about a generation ago but
but we've got the little white picket
fence and the little functional family
and most most families put the fun in
dysfunction i'm just saying
oh this is the ramsey show
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
so
if you guys had any idea how hostile
work environment this is
behind the scenes before the commercials
go off it's unbelievable i don't know
how kelly and james sleep at night man
those two are ruthless uh it's uh
they are ruth yeah
just getting an argument with a phd in
psychology it's it's not healthy
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's true
they're both crying triple eight eight
two five five two two five y'all jump in
we'll talk if you're struggling to keep
up with payments uh you know what it's
like to be scared i do
it's not easy and you don't have to live
like this when you pay off your debt and
you do it quickly you never have to have
that kind of stress in your life again
and you can do this here's where you
start financial peace university
millions of families have taken this
class and learned how to pay off debt
take control of their money and you can
stream all nine lessons right now you
can get some extra support by going
through the class with others and the
only way to get financial peace
university
is through ramsey plus you can get a
free trial to the membership
of ramsey plus by texting trial to 33
don't be held back
put an end to the worry end of the
stress
financial peace university a free trial
at ramsey plus
text trial to thirty three
seven
eighty nine
ishmael is with us in denver colorado hi
ismael what's up
uh yes sir um
i have a
trucking company uh
loaned it for about three years and
just been recently listening to you guys
and uh
learning
the new ropes of how to manage my money
i have about
in the business i have about
32 000 in debt
and then
personally i've got
about
21 000 in student loans
and uh i just wanted to know how
would be the best way to
to budget for the business and then
uh also try to
get out of my
my my hole that i dig myself
so i'm guessing that you own the truck
and you drive the truck and that's your
trucking company
uh yes sir yes there's not other trucks
involved or other drivers involved it's
you and one truck right
hello
uh oh he didn't like your answer dave we
just lost him no i think we just lost
him i didn't do anything offensive yet i
didn't hit him on the uh i'm just keep
lying long enough to be offensive but um
yeah just i'm just getting there but
yeah okay so we'll come back to that
see if we can get him back up in a
second open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five john is in
atlanta hi john how are you
hello good evening um dave and john
question for you so i have i'm sorry
glenn go ahead no that's great
okay
so i have um i have beneficiary set on
my retirement account as well as on my
term life insurance outside of work
and then my life insurance at work and
then the supplemental life insurance i
have at work as well
so i'm trying to understand like when
and why do i need a will
um
in case i well we're not divesting
basically you're single
yes okay well i think your will is going
to be very simple and very clean but i
would have one my guess is you have a
car don't you
uh yes i have a car and mortgage and um
emergency fund money as well okay so
getting possession of that bank account
that car title and getting that house
sold
is going to be 20 times easier with a
will for whoever is left with this job
to do
than it will be without a will because
they're gonna have to go into court and
get permission on every stinking little
thing in probate court if you don't have
a will so your will says i name
so and so how old are you
30 well probably 37 pretty soon and
you're single who would be the executor
of your estate who would be in charge of
handling your estate
um i guess it would be one of my parents
yeah
i haven't decided who yet but one of my
parents well let's just for purposes of
discussion we'll call it your dad okay
yeah or you're let's call it your mom
your mom your mom is gonna be the
executor of the estate an executor the
word executor means execute
their job they're an executor they
execute what the will says it's all they
do
and so if they have a will
she hires an attorney
a few hundred dollars they go to probate
court get the will approved and then the
judge will give the executor
full powers to sell the house
sell the car
sign the title for the car sign the
title to the house clean out the bank
account and use it for the good of the
people in the will now the executor's
job is to do what you said to do in the
will you're going to say sell everything
and give the money to
whoever and that's what the will is
going to say but yes you definitely need
a will
okay go to
mamabearlegalforms.com they're
inexpensive to do online you can do it
very quickly very easily um they've got
some worksheets and stuff that'll help
you get just you know you've got to have
an executor appointed and then you've
got to decide who your heirs are
and the the
more prep you do
before dying the easier it is on
everyone that's left behind
and so this is a gift to people that you
love
is the way you look at a will the way
you look at life insurance the way you
look at naming the beneficiaries you're
obviously a very diligent person anyway
so you're just missing this one thing
but um john my estate plan is very
complicated because there's a bunch of
crap in it and and so
making sure that everybody knows where
they stand what the part is what to
expect what not to expect
those kinds of things in our in my
estate plan
is a gift of mine to the relationships
of the people that are left behind
because people fight more over
what somebody meant to do
that they didn't say
out loud in a will and didn't have
documented properly than they do
anything else just about in families and
when you're grieving you hear things
differently
you imagine things differently i know so
many folks who have already spent money
of estates that they're not even go
right
everything comes to a head i love the
way you say that it's a gift
just think of the people that you love
grieving your loss
and you want to provide them with the
smoothest avenue towards cleaning this
mess up yeah right i mean the antithesis
of it is snarky but is if if you want to
leave your family all fighting with each
other and you think that'd be fun that's
like the ultimate
existential practical joke but you want
to just leave this bunch of jerks all
being jerks to each other forever leave
a very complicated estate with mixed up
directions and not much of a will and
they will go into hyper mode the the the
statement that a buddy gave to me one
time we were just all hanging out and
they said talking about their wills and
i said i don't have one and my buddy
john said
the only reason to not have a will is if
you hate your wife and kids yeah and i
remember thinking oh oh okay right if
you want the state of texas or the state
of tennessee or the state of nebraska
taking care of your family don't have a
will they'll do a great job because they
do a great job taking care of everything
else yeah i mean you've been in that dmv
line lately yeah yeah they'll just still
be great for your weeping
family looking for uh groceries so yeah
man and if you're in his situation
it's a gift to your mom it's a gift to
your dad it's a gift to your loved ones
it's a gift to your nieces or nephews
whoever the beneficiaries are gonna be
of your of your estate
and it doesn't take long less of it goes
to the lawyers less of it goes to the
state
less time is consumed executing your
wishes
when they are clearly laid out in a will
and it's just an absolutely vital thing
i will say this there is not an excuse
to be an adult in the united states i
don't have a will period it's gotten too
cheap you can do it online you can go to
a local attorney's office it's just too
easy to do it's inexcusable to not have
it our sponsor mama bear legal forms is
just they make it very they did mine
that's i i want to see what it was like
and i got a simple will just get it done
yeah and here's the thing wills need to
be state specific yes
which means the state that you are
currently residing
the those laws will apply to your estate
nothing else
so i don't care where you used to live i
don't care where you grew up i don't
care where your property is
the laws in the state you reside in when
you die will apply to your estate
and so if you have moved states your
will may be invalid
uh and if you've had a major
family up evil you've gone through a
divorce or the loss of a loved one or
something you may need to redo your will
when we moved here we did ours right
yeah you should because you're not in
texas anymore and texas law is
considerably different than tennessee
so there you go get it done
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage zachary and tracy are
with us hey guys how are you we're doing
great dave how are you all doing blessed
blessed bless life is good man good to
have you guys where do you live we're
from los angeles california awesome and
all the way to nashville to do a screen
yes sir how much have you paid off
we paid off a hundred fifty thousand
dollars whoa and how long did this take
44 months oh 44 yes all right four cool
and your range of income during that 44
months 78 000 to 150 000 whoa double it
there you go game on what do you guys do
for a living well i'm a manager at a
worldwide media company
and i work from home i'm a stay-at-home
dad
and i run an online company yeah i hope
you're doing voiceovers
you used to be in radio in hawaii
actually yeah yeah you got you got the
pipes for it for sure thank you well
done good for you guys excellent what
kind of debt was the 150
well a hundred thousand of that was
student loans between the two of us and
then the rest was credit card and
miscellaneous okay so you're just kind
of normal just been gathering up how
long you all been married uh we've been
married for over seven years now but
together for a total of 17. okay so what
happened 44 months ago that broke this
loose uh back in 2016 i lost my job at a
company i was
at for 10 years
i started there with 15 people and then
we grew it to about a thousand whoa plus
and um it was basically bought out uh
they attempted to get rid of me and that
discouraged me
uh going back
to any corporate job i was a
repossession manager for auto title loan
company oh
so
i used to be the bad guy
uh so i
it was a blessing in disguise that i was
fired and so after
that had happened i had done uber and
lyft
and amazon deliveries
and eventually that led us to starting
our own e-commerce business and that
plugged us into a lot of online groups
and communities of people who are like
us small business owners
and i noticed that every time somebody
would ask a question about personal
finance your name would pop up and i had
no idea who you had never heard of you
before finally one day i decided to look
you up online and it happened to be
during one of your live shows i saw a
couple do their debt free scream and
after that i was hooked i started
listening to your show regularly for the
total money makeover put together a
budget but i knew that
none of that would
happen unless we were both on the same
page so i told him about financial peace
university and he agreed to take the
class with me and at the time we found
out that we were pregnant so we were
very excited at becoming first-time
parents and it gave us even more
motivation to want to get out of debt
but while we were doing fpu
unfortunately that first pregnancy ended
in a miscarriage
and so that was one of the hardest
things that we went through on this
journey because i lost all motivation i
didn't want to talk to anybody didn't
want to see anybody
and it took time to heal but we got
through it we graduated from financial
peace university and zach was 100 on
board and we both started attacking our
debt together way to go you guys awesome
you fought through a lot yes we did job
loss and
uh miscarriage and everything wow that's
a lot to fight through a lot of
adversity yeah 44 months you kept going
and kept going it kept going you scratch
your way through all that you're gonna
make it yeah that's pretty cool
all right cool and you brought uh your
little daughter with you what's her name
a rainbow baby bella gloriana all right
yes bella for beautiful right
yes all right uh she's ready to see it
is beautiful
she's ready to see mom
i love it way to go what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
um well because we're married a couple
definitely being on the same page none
of this would have happened if we didn't
share the same goals and the same dreams
of wanting to change your family tree
and to build a better future for a
family
and
for me it's budgeting i do i run analyze
online e-commerce
so it's a lot of purchasing selling what
not
and communication has brought us
closer together even though we were
you were married for seven years i mean
and together for 17
we never talked about money until just a
few years ago and another key for us is
um
giving generously before we would only
give like a dollar here a couple dollars
there because we were scared that we
weren't going to have enough money but
when we started the baby steps we
started tithing regularly to our church
and that became the top line of our
budget and every time an opportunity
came up for us to give cool then we
would and we we realized that by
being generous and giving and putting
kindness out into the world god has
blessed us in so many ways oh yeah so
we're very grateful for all of that
that's fun way to go what's the name of
your church um st charles bromeo
catholic church in north hollywood cool
and where did you go to financial peace
university um shepherd of the hill in
porter ranch yeah yeah very good you
guys well i'm proud of you thank you who
are your biggest cheerleaders
uh i have a friend that i speak with
daily uh he he runs the e-commerce
business as well his name is jeff hey
jeff
and um we actually we we kept to
ourselves mostly because we knew that a
lot of our friends and family wouldn't
understand what we were going through um
you know we're all conditioned to
believe that debt is normal that student
loan debt is good debt and that it's
necessary to have a good credit score
and we hope that our friends and family
that are seeing this today will realize
all the sacrifices that we made and why
we had to say no to them so many times
and that they realize um
sorry
um and that they realize that no debt is
good debt and that um real wealth true
wealth doesn't come from a high credit
score hey man why'd it go you guys
yeah
just watching you too love that little
baby girl it's so cool and she's not
going to experience any of this stuff
she'll go through her life's hardships
but she's not going to have this
roadblock in front of her
congratulations guys thank you we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure is that changed legacy way to
go and a copy of the total money
makeover and you can of course give that
to somebody and pay it forward and get
things moving so proud of you guys well
done thank you zachary tracy and bella
beautiful bella los angeles 150 000 paid
off in 44 months making 78 to 150 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three
two one
[Applause]
[Music]
cool man that's fabulous i think little
bella was a little scared i don't know i
think she's heard her parents yell like
that before it's all good
that's so cool man that's so fun what a
great celebration
very very very well done open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
griffin on twitter says john how do i
find a balance between being a
workaholic and being on dave's program
during and after fpu
it's so hard
hmm
i think you've
you've got to have a mission you've got
to have a destination and a deadline and
you've got to do the math and you've got
to work really hard that's gazelle
intensity right
working a lot of hours does not mean
you're a workaholic no that means you're
in a season that's a hyperbole bunch of
drama that's exactly what that is the
definition of a workaholic is
someone who's an addict to work who's
trying to achieve for their self-esteem
right and it goes on for years and years
and years yeah and it this is not
someone who's trying to earn their way
trying to hit a goal that's right
someone working to hit a goal in a
healthy manner and putting in a whole
ton of hours for a short period of time
living like no one else so later they
can live like no one else working like
no one else so later than work like no
one else is not by definition a
workaholic that's what somebody calls
their friend when they used to hang out
and now all of a sudden they're working
really hard so they can get out of debt
and you say you're just a worker
workaholic he's we should talk to him
yeah no he's got a goal in mind he's
laser focused on something well i mean
uh
i think the word is just misused yeah a
lot
and sometimes it's done facetiously and
sometimes it's just people have a bad
definition of it my wife has said in the
past she goes you know back during those
times you were kind of a workaholic and
i really wasn't
i've never in my life drawn well i'd say
maybe in my early 20s i did but other
than that i have not drawn my
self-esteem from my work or my
accomplishments see i have i've had
seasons where i was on call 24 7 and
then joined the police force and then
was working and then if you're not
working for a goal then you're working
trying to fill an empty hole that's
exactly right and that whole
no matter how much money you make how
much you can't throw anything you cannot
that's a workaholic that's a holic
something you know it's something aholic
that's right when you're throwing stuff
in that hole that's what you're doing
but just simply working hard while
you're in financial peace university
working three jobs
so that you never have to again that is
not the definition of workaholics call
the champion go get it brother yeah
that's it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
our scripture today romans 1 16 for i'm
not ashamed of the gospel because it
because it is the power of god that
brings salvation to everyone who
believes
general george patton said better to
fight for something than live
for nothing
ishmael is with us in denver we got him
back talking about his trucking company
if i remember you so ishmael i was
asking you before we lost you you have
one truck and you drive it or you have a
whole staff or what
uh no sir i drive it
basically dispatch my own loads yeah
your trucking company is you and a rig
yes sir okay that's why i want to make
sure i understood what i was talking
about okay so the budget for your
business
is you're already doing one we're just
gonna formalize it
and make it more accurate because you're
forgetting some things you already do
one in your head
because that's why you take
a uh you know you're you're dispatching
your own loads so you take a load
and you know it's going to cost you x
number of dollars in fuel and some
maintenance
to get that load to its destination
right
yep and you take that load and you know
about how many loads you're probably
going to get in a month because how long
you've been doing this
uh
for a little bit for a little over three
years
okay
all right
so you know pretty clearly then
you know in a given month typically in a
in august you're going to make you're
going to make so many loads and your
gross revenue is going to be x you
probably could tell me pretty close to
what august is going to look like if i
asked right
yeah bare minimum i'd say like uh
about
20 000 maybe yeah top top line before
expenses and you might that's the bare
minimum so but more than likely you
think you'll make how much really what's
your real uh
not not not way over but not way under
yeah i would say about five thousand
that's what i was thinking yeah okay
good and if you made twenty five
thousand you could probably tell me what
your expenses would be
fuel for one would be fairly easy to
calculate right
yeah my fuel runs about like 1500 a week
and then
and then if you do 25 000 worth of loads
you're gonna have fuel of six thousand
bucks is that all
uh close to that i would say um well
it's a little bit more some yeah lately
it's been right on the rise okay so
what we're doing is we're doing august
budget you're following me
correct i got 25 000 at the top i'm
going to spend i think seven thousand
four hundred dollars on fuel because
it's on the rise and we're gonna do four
weeks worth of 1500 plus a little bit on
the rise and we're got a pretty good
month going here 25 it's not a bare
bones month
um and then what kind of repairs would
you have in your typical month
i'd say about
um
[Music]
anywhere from like 15 to 2000 maybe all
right let's call it 2 000 we got 7 000
in fuel that's nine what are we gonna
run our uh our food cost at while you're
on the road you see what i'm doing here
i'm just laying it all out i want you to
just put this on a piece of paper you
can do it with a blank yellow pad if you
want
yeah okay that's a budget
that's a budget you're predicting your
revenues and you're predicting your
expenses thereby you're predicting your
profits before the month begins
and when it comes to your debts that you
have you're going to put them in order
smallest to
largest and you're going to begin
knocking them out one by one by one
yep exactly in that order and there's
not a business debt because you signed
personally for it so it's all your debt
you got 32 000 on the business but you
signed that personally you got 21 000 on
personal but you signed that personally
so you you know you've got uh what fifty
three thousand dollars worth of debt you
gotta clear here and you can do that
because you're probably making
yeah you're probably making close to 100
a year
profit aren't you
um get close to about uh last year i
think we're about 75
after expenses
that sounds low but uh but you go back
and run it again i mean you got your
actual taxable income you could look at
your tax return and tell that but yeah
so if you got 75 and are you sleeping in
the rig
uh no no
um
sometimes i'm over the road but most of
the time it's
mostly local so
uh my rent's about
680. okay so now we're starting to run
your personal budget
what you're going to do with your 75 or
your 85 and then how much of that we're
going to be able to apply to this 53 000
in debt so i'm going to predict that
you're going to be out of debt in under
two years
okay and if you get an ice chest and go
to a grocery store and make your lunches
and your breakfast you can get out even
faster yeah because this is i mean 25
000 a year for two years out of 75 would
be 50.
okay and that'd be you'd be debt free in
two years and i think you can do it
faster than that because i really you
ain't got anything to do but work and
get out of debt that's right that's all
you got to do for the next 18 months i
think you can get there but you just
need to get real business-like
about your
trucking budget
which creates your profit and then get
real business-like on that profit and
what we're going to do with it you need
to set 25 of it aside for taxes when you
figure out what your profit is because
you're supposed to be paying quarterly
estimates on your profits and if you
don't you're gonna get a problem
so uh that that's the process and uh you
know you just gotta get out stay up with
your taxes and then you you know pay
your rent pay your light bill by pay
your food bill and get out of debt and
this is what we're gonna do and it's all
gonna be just written down ahead of time
on paper on purpose before the month
begins dave do you recommend somebody
pull out
depreciation on something like that nope
okay no uh what i would do is i would
set aside repair money okay on a truck
because you may not you may not have an
expense on a repair this month but you
will within some period of time so just
on average if we drive that many miles
in a truck you're going to have
x number of dollars in a year of repairs
tires and brakes divided by 12 okay and
i'd be setting that aside monthly so
that when that repair comes up you've
already put the money aside for it in a
sense in a in a truck repair envelope in
a sense okay so you're you're setting
that aside all the time
because typically you're not going to
have an even
repair budget month to month to month to
month even on your personal cards you
don't yeah so uh yeah that's a good way
to do it all right pragati is with us in
jacksonville florida did i say that
right pragati
uh it's pregnancy how are you dave i
knew i was gonna mess it up i'm great
i'm sorry i messed up your name how can
i
uh help yeah i'm a college student um
i've been working
on doing an engineering internship since
january so i have some saved money and
i'm going back to school in three weeks
so i owe about ten thousand dollars but
i'll probably won't need it until i
graduate which is in december of 22.
um i was wondering if i should invest it
should i split it up and invest fifty
percent and put some in savings or what
should i do with it
i'd leave it all in savings and not
touch a dime of it and pay cash for
everything do you get out of school this
is your insurance policy that you
graduate and graduate with no debt
okay because the chances of a tire
blowing of you getting a job interview
but you got to fly yourself there on a
week's notice or these expenses are
going to pop up in your last year keep
that money in account don't spend it and
you will be set up to win we're spending
it on you and you completing this
education and you transitioning into the
new job
that is a better investment than an
investment
i see do you suggest i still have about
6 000 in my savings account do you
suggest um
should i put maybe 30 to 40 percent of
that 10 000 into
high yield savings for a little bit
um high yield savings is an oxymoron
there is no high yield savings high
yield savings is one and a quarter
instead of 0.75 and you lock your money
up it doesn't matter yeah
you're not going to make enough on it to
matter
i mean if if you made 20 on 10 dollars
is two thousand dollars that does not
change your life what changes your life
is you completing your education and you
going and getting the new job that's
worth a lot of money and then in a year
if you get there and you've got the car
you've got the clothes that you need for
this new job you're ready to rock and
roll and you still have sixteen thousand
dollars in the bank then you get into
investing yep
good for you though incredible thing way
to go great so proud of you very very
well done john good hour john dr john
deloney check him out on the dr john
delony show our very popular podcast
from ramsey networks
james charles is our producer kelly
daniel is our associate producer and
phone screener i'm dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
send clips to your friends download the
ramsay network app in your favorite app
store today